thanks a lot for inviting me over and
thanks everybody for coming it's always
exciting to
yeah and it's fun this is Ian video type
auditorium great match because I'm
mostly going to talk about stuff that
we've actually done at the Nvidia lab
over the last year's just a quick
background I start at two and a half
years ago first with an 80% position at
Nvidia starting a robotics lab and now
I'm currently on a half half an half
position with the universities so back
back to teaching as well and this all
came about when I had a meeting with
with Chancellor Wong the CEO of Nvidia
talking about robotics and what are the
the hot areas where this new kind of
robotics really has an impact on
industrial settings and what's of course
already happening right now is really
robots in warehouses moving around
navigating through hospitals hotels of
course of driving cars it's the big
elephant in the room always but what we
wanted to look at in the research side
is really robots that are not just about
navigating around but robots that
physically interact with the environment
so if you match in self-driving cars of
course the main focus is not to
physically interact with your
environment maybe with the tires but
otherwise you don't want to crash into
anything so if you want to have a look
at these kind of robots and it's really
about interacting with the environment
touching things doing this in close
proximity to people around you and
application domains of these kind of
robots is of course industrial
manufacturing and you've heard some
recent exciting news about where these
kind of deep learning technologies for
example I have an impact on manipulation
settings in industry but also people
with physical disabilities a colleague
at Georgia Tech Charlie Kemp is
investigating for example how robots can
help people with physical disabilities
here in a case even where the robot
might help shaving the person of pulling
up a blanket when the purse is lying in
the bed so you can imagine that in these
cases the robot really has to kind of be
in contact with a person and all of this
has to be safe but at the same time the
robot has to have kind of the perception
capabilities to reason about what is
going on around
right any general helping people elderly
people in hospitals so this is kind of
the goal for this kind of work and we
realize of course there's still a lot of
research to be done or to do this so we
started the robotics lab in Seattle two
and a half years ago we're currently 12
research scientists we have over the
summer for example we had 20 interns
last year several of them are here in
the room from Stanford it was really fun
working with with all these smart people
what I want to talk about today though
is one project that we started in the
lab and that is about getting a robot to
do certain tasks in a kitchen and we're
clearly not doing cooking yet but we
chose kitchen kind of s and integrate a
test environment right in which we can
look at different aspects of this
manipulation problem or puzzle right
this is the kitchen we have the Nakia
kitchen just bought down the road we
also have a simulation model of that and
the idea for the kitchen is really that
again we can integrate different
manipulation components into it we can
do task planning motion planning and
things like that but also you can make
it in a staged way more and more complex
right so initially actually as you'll
see today it's mostly very simple tasks
like just pick up an object and move it
somewhere but then on the longer run you
can make it more and more complicated by
introducing people into the kitchen so
the robot has to start interacting with
them has to understand what the person
wants to do and maybe help the person
cooking and even maybe helping with
preparing ingredients or cooking
ultimately itself but the idea is that
many of these tasks really just stand in
for many of these other application
events you could imagine for example
also in industrial manufacturing the
specific thing we wanted to look at
initially it's really that let's assume
we have this kitchen here and we make
the very strong assumption that we have
a 3d model of the kitchen which means we
know where the drawers are we know where
the doors are and we even have 3d models
of the objects you might have seen the
famous spam can is kind of from the ycb
object data set I'm kind of
tire of it but just looking at it not
even eating I haven't eaten any of them
but also yeah the cheesy box these kind
of objects so the idea was under these
super-strong assumptions can we build a
system that can do let's say reasonably
simple pick-and-place tasks like just
opening a drawer and getting an object
out of out of it on the perception side
we use actually in this case just
because we didn't want me to put
actually depth camera on the robot
itself we have like two depth cameras
and looking at the kitchen and then the
idea is use them to to track what's
going on in there okay the robot base is
sakata that is used by nvidia by the
Issac SDK team that is focusing so for
more on navigation system building a
navigation stack also with very strong
support of course for deep learning and
GPU processing and we put a franca arm
on top and for some of the more recent
work also we could we put a depth camera
onto the wrist of the robot so that you
can get close up if you want to pick up
objects so if you think about what's
involved in such a manipulation task
then on the high level EF is what people
call task and motion planning so a sub
part of their Waskom is focusing on this
where you say you know where objects are
for example in the world you have the
geometric models of everything and then
you wanna for example let's say if I set
the table then you say the target
configuration is that the plate in the
fork a knife on the table and then you
have a high level let's say more logic
planning based descriptions or where you
say well for the table for example if
the table is in the drawer in order for
the robot to be able to pick up the
plate not not the table if the plate is
in the drawer for the robot to get the
plate or the drawer the drawer has to be
open in things like that so you have
preconditions on actions and then you
can chain these and can come up with a
plan that achieves a desired
configuration okay this is tasks in
motion planning and what you do jointly
with this high-level planning is also
the actual motion planning for the robot
so that it can achieve these tasks and
the other thing of course if you want to
execute it in the real world you need
state estimation you need to know
actually
what is the status of the world where
the objects are and I'm going to talk
about that a bit more then you need to
be able to grasp and place objects and
again here we take advantage of the fact
that we have 3d models of objects and we
can more or less pre specify all these
different components and then the final
ingredient is then on the manipulator
itself you need a controller that
actually executes all these planned
motions ok
so in this talk I just want to go
through some of these these areas and
give you an example for the kind of work
we've done in in debt and then later
I'll give one more example on how we
expand the grasping to unknown objects
ok so the first part is we've done a lot
of work on 60 object post estimation and
I know this is some really cool and
exciting work of course going on here as
well so we're kind of working ourselves
a long side
to this problem and the idea is of
course if you have an object and you
want to manipulate it let's say this is
our famous cheesy box and you have a 3d
model of the object and you want the
robot for example to pick it up then one
approaches that you want to estimate
where it is relative to the robot ok so
the task is you get an image and the
option is in the image and you want to
know for example in that specific image
what is the 3d position and 3d
orientation of the object that's why
it's a 60 estimation problem okay so
it's orientation and translation and
this of course a lot of work has been
going on in the computer vision
community especially been focusing on
this problem for quite a while there's
many standard data sets on how to
evaluate your technique a lot of the
focus has actually been on kind of
single image estimation which means you
get a single image of the scene and then
you immediately go to an estimate for
the 60 pose of the object and again a
lot of really cool work coming out of
out of Stanford here and the typical
approach most recently has also been for
example on just regressing more or less
the image to a 60 pose estimate right
using deep learning and using
large-scale
training data sets the focus of these is
also that you really want to regress the
process
to a unique post of the robot and it
turns out if you have symmetric objects
then the question is whether that even
makes sense whether whether they say
uniquely defined 60 posts and I'll talk
about it on the next slide a bit more
and then there's other work on trekking
but again there it's also just kind of a
unimodal estimate Kalman filter style
and there's one exception where they use
the particle filter but it turns out
that if you just use a standard particle
filter for sampling this full 60 space
then it also boils down more or less to
just being able to do tracking because
the 60 post space of these objects is
pretty complicated as I'll show you next
so what we wanted to focus on is really
estimating now the full 60 post
distribution and uncertainty and doing
that even for symmetric objects okay so
why is orientation uncertainty actually
not as simple as you might think let's
imagine this is an object like tunic and
I think in this case and this is the
only observation you get right so now
the question is what is the orientation
of the of the object or the the
equivalent question is what is the
camera viewpoint onto that object given
that image okay and it turns out of
course that you have quite some
uncertainty in the orientation that you
cannot resolve based on that single
image because you could be anywhere the
camera could be any way around the
object right or it could even be in this
case if it's symmetric you could kind of
view the object from the bottom part now
you might say that that is just because
people are using depth cameras and they
don't know how to use texture and visual
information so if you now use a textured
model of the object and you also use
color then you might be able to actually
resolve that uncertainty and you have
kind of a unimodal distribution of where
you are relative to the object does it
make sense okay so on the one hand side
of course color helps you resolve some
uncertainties but then even in this case
even if you have that object model if
you're looking at some point at the
object from the
then even in this situation you still
don't know where your are relative to it
even if you use if you have a textured
object right so to summarize this part
is really that on the one hand side
these symmetries result in pretty
complex actually distributions and you
cannot predefined actually the shape of
these distributions in advance because
it often depends on your specific
viewpoint and it depends on certain
occlusions you have in the scene right
you might have specific uncertainties
just because a specific part of an
object is occluded and because of that
you can't resolve it so what we wanted
to do is we want to do 60 pulse
estimation where we keep track of these
full distributions here the first
approach here is and that is actually
borrowing the idea of Santa Maya and in
colleagues they had there was actually
best paper at ECC V in 2018 and they
kind of their focus was specifically on
orientation uncertainty over objects
okay
I just want to give you a brief summary
on how that works imagine you have this
object and what they're learning is kind
of a a code book for certain views onto
this object so the idea is that you have
an auto encoder and you train this with
pairs of input images and output images
okay so the goal of the auto encoder is
to take a noisy image of the object a
view onto the object from a let's say
normalized distance to the object and it
has to learn to encode this in this case
at 128 dimensional codeword draw such
that you can decode it into a clean
image of the object okay and you do this
with many pairs right different
viewpoints and in the sense what the
network learns is to kind of take input
or not noise the image and encode it
such that you can specifically also
recover the viewpoint onto the object I
hope that makes sense
and again you do this for many pairs and
once it's trained you can now go and in
their case
you just can't generate ninety two
thousand something views different
viewpoints onto the object and for each
viewpoint you just store the code that
the encoder generates for that view
okay and now during testing if someone
gives you an image of the object you
throw away the decoder because actually
you don't need that you encode that and
then what you do is you just compare the
code word with your codebook use
adjusted cosine similarity measure then
that similarity tells you which view
from which view you're looking at the
object yeah and then what they did in
their work it just shows the most
similar and said like okay that is the
orientation of the object okay the nice
thing is if you have let's say a
symmetric object like this one that if
you look at it from here then it will
match very well every view that is
around this object that has the same
that looks the same right so it very
naturally recovers or encodes this
notion of that objects might look the
same from different orientations great
the similar the the limitations of that
work is that if they only really cared
about getting the single orientation out
of it and they didn't worry about
different translations of the objects
and also it was just a single image in a
single estimate but this is kind of the
foundation for what we did then where we
said we want to incorporate that into a
full 60 post tracking framework and for
that we developed this technique called
post our BPF our vp f stands for raw
black rice particle filtering so we
thought we're gonna bring in some good
old particle filtering into here where
the ideas particle filtering is you'd um
represent densities or uncertainties by
samples that represent then the the high
density areas by having most
samples in that area and the idea of
this specific route black oval eyes
particle filters this is just rather
than saying for example I'm going to
sample this full 60 post space what I'm
going to do is I'm going to sample
certain parts of the state space and
others I'm gonna solve analytically
conditioned on the samples
okay people have used this in different
contexts like activity recognition you
might have heard here from stanford
sebastian front of nicola they
introduced fast slam where what they
they decouple the slam problem by
sampling trajectories of the robot and
for each sample trajectory they would
then build a map right so now you have a
sample based representation that
encapsulate both uncertainty of the path
and uncertainty of the map that
corresponds to that in our case we use
the same idea but here what we say is
we're gonna sample the translation of
the object which is XYZ and we're gonna
solve for the orientation using just a
discrete distribution so here's how this
works each particle now has a
translation again XYZ where's the object
and the full distribution over the
rotation conditioned on the translation
of that object okay so what that means
is we first can take an image like this
one here and if we have a particle that
has a specific translation that will
give us a specific bounding box for the
object in the image if the translation
says that the object is further away
then the bounding box will be smaller
for example things like that right and
it moves throughout the image and then
we can feed this region of interest that
corresponds to that single particle we
can encode it and compare it to the same
code book that you saw by the Sunnah
Meyer work in our case we have even more
bins for the annotation you 191,000
which is 191,000 orientations okay and
then that gives you the likelihood and
that likelihood is what you use to
weight your particles and then you do
over time you can do the resampling and
very standard party
filter techniques right there's nothing
special about it the only insight was
here really to say we do the seemingly
crazy thing of having every particle
with like these almost two hundred
thousand bins that represent the
possible orientations and we can do this
of course efficiently because we only
need to compute the code once per
particle and then the comparison with
the codebook that's of course on a GPU
you can do this all in parallel so then
why we can do all of this then in real
time okay let me just show you an
example on the right side you see the
particle do the kind of the orientation
uncertainty and these are the different
bounding boxes of the different
particles okay and what's interesting
here is that initially when the handle
of the mark let me play this again when
the handle of the mug is not visible the
uncertainty is actually much larger in
the orientation right because you don't
know where it is exactly but then when
the handle comes into view the
uncertainty really goes down
significantly okay so it really nicely
handles all these kind of different
viewpoints another thing of course you
can do now is even though this is kind
of a technique that is only based on
kind of this let's say local region of
image of interest images you can't just
do global localization which means you
can do detection with this technique as
well where what you do is you just
randomly throw out how many five
thousand particles this is these are the
bounding boxes of these five thousand
particles and because we don't need to
sample the orientation we do it
analytically again through this full
distribution it very quickly actually
converges then to the right pose and
then we can even reduce the number of
particles and then track the object
through time okay and again this can be
done pretty faster with at the end the
tracking fifty particles was twenty
frames per second and now I think
gingka this wasn't Gingka did this as an
intern he has it to more than 30 frames
per second actually if they're tracking
okay
so now what we have is we can estimate
the poses of these individual objects
but of course in this let's say in this
kitchen setting you also want to
estimate where the doors the drawers are
and things like that for that we use a
technique that my student Tanishq it
introduced a while ago it's called dart
thence articulated real-time tracking
and the idea here is that if you have a
3d shape model of an articulated object
could be a robotic manipulator could
also be furniture or things like that
then it's a very fast again GPU based
implementation of if you have a depth
based observation of a scene you can
then match your depth information
against the model and estimate the
articulation okay so here the problem is
that the estimation is not just let's
say a 60 pose of a hand but we also need
to estimate the joints of the hand as
well okay and the nice thing is in this
case since it's just purely model-based
it's very general so it can be applied
to any of these settings okay so you can
see the TREC model alongside with the
point load and we've done it also for
some robot manipulation tasks at that
time already the key limitation is it
needs to be initialized right because
the search space is too high dimensional
and also that it's reasonably brittle
which means if for example your model
doesn't match well if you don't have a
correct model then the tracking might
fail or if tracking fails reinitialize
ation is also not that easy so actually
nowadays of course also you can do the
follow-up for many of these tasks you
can do it of course through just deep
learning if you have enough training
data okay but once we have that
framework now we can kind of apply to
the whole kitchen where what you see
here is kind of this fuzzy stuff is
going to be the point cloud that we see
from the depth camera data and the
coloring indicates what object the
different points are associated with and
what we can do is we can use the
technique that I just told you to get
the initial pose of objects and here we
take just the most likely orientation
and then we can use this to initialize
start so we're running dart to track
these individual objects and we're
running dart to track also where the
robot is in the scene and also to track
the status of the furniture kind of of
the cabinets so you'll see here on the
upper aides I might not be perfectly
time synth but you can see the ball but
now moving in and we're using now the
dart estimates to tell the manipulator
where it should move in order to pick up
the object yeah this one is a bit
lagging behind I'm sorry
and again this only works of course if
you have a good model off of that scene
right but we can do all of this now
fully autonomously and now and one
problem was for example with this
initial system is if the depth camera is
too far away you're not going to get the
object post actually accurately enough
so that you could really always grab it
so now what we have is we have a depth
camera also on the on the wrist of the
arm and then you get a more accurate
pulse estimate for the object that you
actually want to pick up okay but the
nice thing is we can do all this
tracking in a single joint optimization
over all the poses of these objects and
the robot and also you can incorporate
physical constraints into that
estimation problem such as for example
objects shouldn't interpenetrate and
things like that okay so the final piece
to the puzzle here then the manipulator
control and for that we're using a
technique that Nathan Ratliff introduced
it's called this Romanian motion
policies where the problem is that let's
say if you have a rough trajectory of
how the robot arm should move then you
what you need to generate at a very high
frequency you need to generate control
commands for the manipulator and of
course that's been one of the some of
the most fundamental work has happened
here also especially with Ossama Khatib
slap and then the idea is that
you wanna do reasoning actually in the
task space in the geometric space that
is going on here
but you need to generate control
commands for the motors for the joints
of the robot okay so how this approach
is working is you can define you define
points for example on the robot just
give you some examples
okay and for these points you can now
define or you can compute for example
features in the environment such as what
is the closest obstacle to that point um
multiple of them you can also define for
example for this one for the gripper you
can define for example what is the
direction of the goal point where you
want the the end effector to actually go
in the workspace yeah and what it gives
you is for each of these points
depending on for example the proximity
of these obstacles and things like that
it's going to give you a desired
acceleration where that point would like
to move and these accelerations can also
take into account the velocity so for
example when you're moving along an
obstacle that it will not penalize that
so it will kind of allow you to smoothly
move for long obstacles and then once
you have defined all of these then you
can combine them all together and
compute the accelerations of then
actually in the controls in the joint
space of the robot okay so you define
things in the operational space and then
you pull them back into the joint space
and here's just an example kind of this
is a robot that doesn't like open
drawers and this is Nathan in the
background and what we're doing here is
we're using dart to track the status of
the cabinet right and then the robot as
you can see can generate these pretty
nice smooth motions important thing to
mention Scott that his armies it's still
a local technique right it's still kind
of just mapping from the current state
in velocities to accelerations so you
still have to kind of have on top of
that a global trajectory optimizer or a
path window here's another example now
all of this put together this is work
that Chris Paxton did
how you now let's assume if you do
higher-level planning and you want a
robot to execute such a plan then one
technique that people are using is
called this behavior trees which are
kind of just observing the current state
and then based on that they're
generating what kind of discrete mode
for example the system should be in and
Chris developed these logical dynamical
systems that then for some in this case
let's assume the robot wants to put the
spam into the drawer and there's pretty
robust to these kind of perturb insists
right so it's constantly just kind of
checking the state of the system of the
environment and then sees if for example
preconditions for certain actions are
still fulfilled
so it pretty smoothly and quickly right
can't react to all of that and we can
later on of course we can have a
discussion on that like you could not
argue you can do all of this in an
end-to-end way but I think the advantage
of the model-based techniques is really
that you can now really put on top of
this a really long term task in motion
planner right that it's very general it
can and can generate these these
behaviors let me just give you one more
example this is a project that Cailin
Garrett he's a student MIT with Leslie
kelp Lee and Thomas Lozano press working
on tasks and motion planning which is
exactly this higher-level reasoning and
actually most of the work that you see
these days is still happening purely in
simulation which means that task more
spending is they generate these
scenarios and then they evaluate how
fast they can do the planning in this
scenarios but often they don't really
work in the real world yet because the
perception isn't good enough but now
with having a system here that has
pretty good perception we can actually
start running these tasks and motion
planning systems in the real world so in
this case the task is in the focus of
that paper is also on dealing with with
uncertainty or not knowing certain
things so in this case the robot knows
that this
I think it's miss Pam again yes spam
again is in one of the two top drawers
and it should figure out in which one
and then put it in the other one okay
and in this case the motion is actually
he didn't use the RM piece but the full
perception system that we have so you
can reason about okay so it's gotta be
the upper drawer and then detects it in
the Aqua drawer and then you can do all
the kind of planning with again the
preconditions and all of that so you can
specify these tasks at a very high level
of abstraction then the planner figures
out the rest and then we can execute it
now actually in the real world okay and
we're currently putting all the pieces
together so that we can also do some
longer-term benchmarking of that system
so you could imagine if you run this on
whatever hundreds of tasks for many
hours how often is it gonna fail because
I'm sure it's gonna fail once in a while
and because what are these failure cases
right so far the failure cases that
we've seen when the cameras are just off
ball is really if the post estimation of
these objects isn't accurate enough and
things like that and that brings me also
now to the next point where actually the
idea is can we get away with without
this explicit 60 pulse estimation for
manipulation tasks okay so so far again
we assume that we have 3d models of
these objects and if you have that model
and you can detect where it is then you
can also determine which grasp you want
to use for example but of course
ultimately you want to be able to do all
of this without object models right and
I want to talk a bit about some of the
more recent work we've done in that
direction in order to cross unknown
objects on the one hand side of course
you want to use training data for deep
networks if you want to solve this
problem with deep learning and here we
used flex similar later in video system
where the idea is you have a model of an
object and you can just sample thousands
of possible grasps and then you run the
simulator in order to evaluate whether
that's a good grasp or not right and you
can do this all in parallel on the GPU
with with with many instances of this
class and you can do this with many
objects and then you do some
perturbations on it to figure out
whether the grasp is actually also
stable or robust to these perturbations
okay and then what you get is for
example maybe for these objects you get
some training data that tells you for
that object these are the 60 graphs that
actually worked yeah and you can do this
now for whatever thousands of objects
and in this specific piece of work that
most probably ICCB with by arsalan last
year and I want to note the code and
everything is available for that if you
want to look into this
it's the idea is that we train a deep
network that looks at the point load of
an object and then samples grass that
have a high chance of succeeding okay
how we do this is let's assume you have
an input image and we use the point loud
what makes this problem with trickier
then if you do it in the in the
simulated world is that we have
occlusions and things like that right so
we want to train a network to actually
just observe the point loss so these the
backside of the object for example you
can't even see okay so now what we do
with this is we first have a deep
network and I'll go a bit into the
detail of that we have a deep network
that takes that as input and samples
grass for it okay and since the grass
same place actually might make a mistake
because it's not trivial we have another
network that kind of an evaluator
discriminator that takes us in put a
configuration of a sampled grasp and the
object point cloud so we're using
pointing at plus plus further for the
deep networks here and it just is
trained to predict whether that's going
to be a successful grasp or not okay
so you can imagine this as being
something that's cleaning up some of the
sampled grass and and refines them okay
and we can also use this as a set for
refinement where we say actually the
grasp evaluator since it's a deep
network you can also propagate backwards
through the network to increase the
probability of success with respect to
the 60 poles of the gripper and by
iterating through this you can actually
move the gripper into a configuration
that has a higher chance of succeeding
yeah let me just go into the grass
sampling here and again this is one of
these order encoders in this case a
conditional variational order encoder
where the idea is through the simulation
we get a successful grasp okay and we
encode this as the point cloud of the
object along with the 60 gripper pose
relative to the object so it's all
centered around the object coordinate
frame but as seen from the camera so we
don't know the internal coordinate frame
of the object itself okay and then we
want to encode this into in this case
the 2d latent space such that the 2d
value along with the object model again
can be decoded into
the 60 grasp okay so the idea is we want
to be able instead if that Layton's face
was 60 then of course you could just
copy that value over right but the idea
is we can actually compress the 60 grasp
face into a 2d space if we condition it
on the object point lot okay and to
train this and then the decoder of
course again generates that a grasp kind
of reconstruction and the loss is then
just the difference between the position
that the network generated versus the
position you put in okay and you train
this again on many of these successful
grasps and the network then learns to go
from the weight from the point cloud yes
to to kind of encode the 60 space into
the 2d space okay and then I'll tell you
how we're going to use this now once we
have trained that latent space we can
then later on kind of throw in this case
we throw away the encoder in the
previous work with this particle
filtering we threw away the decoder here
we can throw away the encoder because
later what we can do is we can then take
a point loud sample a latent value and
the network is gonna give us a 60 grasp
for that okay and we also actually have
a more recent version that is working
even better that it's just using
actually the again approach for that
yeah that's again formulation that just
came out last year that works actually
even better but the idea is is the high
level ideas very very similar it's just
a more robust training for this
embedding space okay so here's what this
might look like then for example here's
this bowl and what Athlon did here if
you move through this 2d latent space
then these are grasps that the network
would sample conditioned on the latent
value okay and
if you for example choose a different
trajectory let's say through that space
you're getting kind of this wrapping
around the rim of the bowl and since we
train it on different objects different
object types the same latent space can
be used on different objects and then
for example in this case this would be
an area where it's trying to generate
grass around the handle so this is the
grass sampler and then to clean up this
grass again we have another network that
takes this input the point cloud of the
object along with a point cloud
representing the gripper relative to the
object okay and then it's a point nipple
of not plus plus let's just trained to
say whether that's going to be
successful or not and we're using the
same simulated training data for that
so essentially what it does is if you
look at this would be an example for
example as input to the network and then
the score would be awkward 1 3 and again
you can now propagate that through the
network with respect to the post of the
gripper
so that you can increase the score and
you can do this iteratively right where
then the network generates a grass that
has a higher chance of success makes
sense and then we can put this all
together and here's just some results
there was at the time of the ICCB
submission we had 88% grass success rate
this is actually 88% on the very first
attempt right which means of course if
you allow it to regress then we're
getting much closer to a hundred and
these were objects that were not first
of all it was only trained in simulation
and the models of these objects were not
in the training data right and now the
most recent version actually we trained
a new network which is a single network
that we trained on more than 8,000
objects and more than 200 shapener
classes so it's a very general network
so it's not focus on a single object
type or so you can also actually train
it on a specific object type but then of
course it doesn't general
as well hey one extension to that is now
on a Miss if the timing works too
cluttered scene and something that's
going to come up at liquor where the
idea is imagine you have this scene so
far we assume that we have only the
single object okay the point load of
this object but if you have a more
cluttered scene then what we can do is
we had a paper call last year where you
can segment the scene you see even if
the objects are not known so unknown
object instant segmentation and let's
assume someone tells you hey pick up
object number three doesn't matter which
class we can now of course first of all
we can kind of cut out that part around
that object from the scene which is this
kind of red rectangle here and now we
can take this crop point cloud first we
can segment out in this case it's the
master we can segment that mastered out
and can feed that into the grass there
to generate good grass for it
and then we have another net work
another network the collision net that's
not going to look at this grass and
predict which of those are going to be
in collision or not okay now you might
say that you don't need this collision
net because you just do collision checks
on your point load but it turns out that
that is actually much better at
detecting collisions with occluded areas
right because there was also trained on
these full object models so it learned
to kind of predict collisions even if
you don't see it in the point cloud
yeah so it's significantly better than
just using the raw observation data and
once you have that you can now of course
choose graphs that are not in collision
with anything and have a much higher
chance of succeeding
even in clutter so here's an example
situation where let's say this is the
outside view on the raw but this is the
view from the robots wrist camera and I
think we want to pick up in this case
the the white mark and we do the
segmentation
the goal we do the segmentation of the
scene and then we can check which of
these are mostly contributing to the
coalition of the grass that we want to
execute in this case it would pick the
one that was mostly contributing to this
and then they can just do grass blending
on that object and you can get this out
of the way and then just the same check
on the scene again and now it can say ok
I can actually pick up the the white cup
to another segmentation round and you
can pick it up okay so now we can start
even without having any object model in
there right no 3d model of existing
objects or reasoning or 60 pose we can
really do start doing more and more
complex actually manipulation tasks in
this setting okay and you can also
imagine that you can use a very similar
approach to do placement right where car
placement is very related to the
grasping problem right where you would
say I have a point cloud that I'm
observing and you can now start sampling
stable placements for an object on a
surface and you can now then you can
actually do the full kind of cross
felling where you're reason about
picking an option up and putting it on
another stable position all all without
using any 60/60 object poses also and
also what Arthur is looking at right now
doing this also with visual feedback in
real time I wanna just briefly say
something about the role of simulation I
think of course simulation is going to
be a really really big plus for robotics
right I think these simulators are
nowadays are becoming more and more
realistic both on the physics side but
also on the photorealistic rendering
side and training robots in in
simulation is gonna be very powerful
just to save time make it awesome more
safe and and clearly more efficient and
in simulation you can provide much more
details on the training data than if you
would do it just in the real world where
you often don't have access to the
internal state for example of the
objects so one example here's of course
how we're training
most of our visual detection systems is
just in simulation where you can just
place your objects into a scene and you
can randomize over the lighting
conditions and then we see if this video
wants to play whatever he wants to write
oh yeah
Oh interesting huh
okay not playing it not not you get the
idea so you can the good thing you can
put these Octavia's also seen where you
can put the objects into drawers and
things like that so that you can
simulate more realistic viewpoints if
the objects are in cluttered scenes
there's a lot of of course like
randomizing the colors and things like
that so that your detectors become
robust I would like to be able to say
that we solve this problem now which
means we can train everything purely in
simulation it's gonna work right away
perfectly well in the real world we have
not figured it out yet so that it's
really working as well as if you would
add some additional real-world data to
it and I haven't seen any techniques
that really perfectly transfer from the
simulator to the real world even on the
perception side okay so what we have a
paper coming out with Ikra where the
robot then collects a small amount of
additional training data for the for
example for the detection networks and
that improves the results them still
over just doing it in simulation in the
same of course for control where we can
now train robots and policies in
simulated environments and there again
similar these ideas with domain
randomization where in this case you
might not know how long that rope is or
you might not know the mass and the size
of that little cylinder that you want to
put in there you can randomize over that
and train policies for this this is work
that Afghan chebotar did and probably
Aramis is now working on a technique
that's called base sim where the idea is
we do most of the training in the in the
simulation and then we go into the real
world to a small number of rollouts
in order to hopefully refine the
simulation and then get away with
training something that works well in
the real world but only requires a
minimum amount of real-world experience
let's say ok and we see a lot of work in
this direction going on in general right
but what this work by Fabio Ramos was at
ours last year does is really phrase
this as a Bayesian estimation problem
where you have a sim
later that has certain parameters you
treat the simulator as a black box but
it has certain parameters and you
generate many rollouts and with that you
learn an invertible model that goes from
statistics over these rollouts back to
distributions over likelihood over the
parameters and then you can update them
over time and refine your sampling
distributions using the real-world
rollouts okay so I think simulation is
gonna be really useful for perception
for control but also just for testing
your whole robot system so here's an
example of our robot in the real kitchen
and one of them is actually a simulated
version of that kitchen so we worked
with the Nvidia the content creation
team that generated a pretty nice
realistic simulation of the kitchen I'm
sure by now most of you have seen which
one is which but I'm sure a little bit
more work might have made it even more
similar but it's not trivial to see
anymore right so that kind of hints at
what is possible with these kind of
simulators right also on the
photorealistic rendering side okay so
the goal would be that you can actually
run your robot control system again this
against the simulator and as we know
there might be some times you might have
to do some debugging and things like
that right so you can do this against
the simulator if the simulation is
realistic enough and it's still actually
a major effort to develop a simpler
photorealistic and especially also a
physically realistic simulation of such
an environment so how to do content
creation for these kind of settings it's
also one of the big open questions
alright I'm coming to my last slide here
mainly and I think we've seen the huge
huge progress especially also thanks to
deep learning on the perception side on
individual components and what I talked
about today is kind of this attempt of
bringing these different pieces together
so that we can solve kind of larger
scale problems right that go all the way
from the low-level control to the
high-level task planning and all the
perception and I think it will be really
useful to move more towards these
systems because often by doing that you
really learn about what's working what's
not
working and for that you really need to
integrate these different components and
I think as a robotics community we need
to start thinking more about
benchmarking environments in which we
can really test our different algorithms
against each other not only on let's say
simple tasks like just picking up an
object but much more in the context of
larger scale tasks I think being in the
nvidia auditorium of course and videos
super well-suited I think for really
driving a lot of the progress in
robotics right on the one hand side it's
clearly of course GPU acceleration for
for deep learning and inference
perception these robots will need more
and more perception and learning so that
that's a clear case but also I think the
simulation video has of course a lot of
experience on physics based simulation
photorealistic rendering from gaming and
computer graphics and I think that's
gonna be really important moving all of
this forward various open questions I
think one interesting events that really
keeps on coming up is how do we
represent these environments you saw
today there's one the first part was
more about really explicit
representations of the world right
explicit shape models explicit reasoning
about things like 60 posts and
everything and an alternative is more
like the second part that I described
which is more implicit right like the 60
grasped net that generous grasp of an
object on the one hand side you might
say the network has no idea of what it's
doing but obviously if it can generate
good grass for different objects it must
implicitly have these kind of reasoning
capabilities right and the questioner is
we're on the long run should we be on on
that right like how much 3d knowledge
for example should we inject into the
deep networks in order to do the
learning better and I think and clearly
we've seen some also nice recent work on
3d voxel-based representations that are
not explicitly recovering 3d shape but
just recover kind of a 3d shape feature
space that is then well-suited for
certain tasks like matching objects into
a scene and things like that so I think
the earth this is a really one of the
big questions that the earth that I'd be
happy to discuss some more also the same
of course on the controls
right we need to learn representations
obviously that are not just good for a
specific task a labeling task but they
have to be good in the context of
control tasks and of course like the
work the Chelsea is doing here is also
really interesting direction this in
this really interesting work in this
direction of course simulation how close
are we
there's still many different components
that I think are still missing there
right how do we do seem to real better
content creation is going to be a big
problem if you want to train our robots
in thousands of environments they have
to look pretty good so who's going to do
this for us
of course the furniture manufacturers
they often have 3d models if they would
be willing to share with us all this
months I think that would be really cool
touch sensing is a really big area still
on the one hand side on the hardware
itself right and I saw some exciting
work today kind of building better touch
sensors but also then how to take
advantage of visit because it could
should clearly be connected to this and
again I think benchmarking is going to
be a big question moving forward so with
that thank you very much also this is
the lab and of course many of the great
interns we've been working with again
several of them here if I have one more
minute I can just show you one think
that I didn't turn out is like something
like this just to show you that we're
not only doing kitchen kind of stuff but
this is work that uncle Honda has done
on that expired it's gonna be at across
where the ideas he built with multiple
def cameras are I could hand tracking
system and then they can in real time
well 1/6 of real-time here want to be
really open about this but you can
actually get the robot to do pretty cool
stuff so the idea is that he's standing
next to the robot and he's kind of
moving the hand that then in real-time
gets first you track it but you cannot
just copy the joints over but you have
to cut because the shape of the allegro
hand is different so you have to do some
real reading to that but then you can
actually get this hand to do pretty cool
things right that in the fully automated
way is just not possible yet and you can
use this then moving forward maybe also
for imitation learning and things
that and of course touch sensing year
we've done good bunch of touch sensing
work using the biotech sensors here to
pick up objects but also just to learn
kind of models of these touch sensors
right so that you can go from the in
this case electron measurements to
contact points and contact directions
and things like that alright with that
thank you for attention
[Applause]
between my eyesight and my touch bugs I
think it's a combination of both you
really want to use and I think that's
also what what we do right like for
example the visual perception gives me
clearly first of all it tells me where I
have to put my head move my hand in
order to grasp it and it also gives me a
pretty good prior on where I should grab
it but then of course at some point
clearly it's touch that takes over right
so I can clearly then close my eyes and
I can do all of these things so I think
it's not either/or it's a combination of
those clearly
not a lot and they're also Jeanette and
the men people are doing some really
cool work in that domain I think as
you've seen we we were able to we're
also moving in this direction but it's
clearly not soft yet and again one of
the problems also we just don't have
robot hands that have touch sensing on
the palm and everything we're still kind
of stuck to kind of fingertip kind of
sensing on that side and then again I
think a lot of the work that we are
seeing is kind of still pretty isolated
way it's about like learning a
predictive model of kind of what happens
if I rotate my finger and things like
that or slip detection but I I haven't
really seen a lot of work so that you
can really feel like yeah this is
working for arbitrary objects or things
like that on Edwin in hand manipulation
is also a problem yeah yeah that's an
interesting sexually with the one video
I shot that was actually exactly that
case wait this one here so we're
not your play yeah when we actually
wanna grab the white coffee cup right
and we can segment the scene and then we
can reason about these other segments
and we can reason about how much are
they in the way of being able to grasp
it and I think actually so on the one
hand side what you could do is you could
do now the full complex planning where
you say exactly in which order do I need
to pick which object in order to grab
than this one and what might be the
optimal ordering I think for many of
these scenes reasonably simple
heuristics might actually work pretty
well and I'm pretty sure that I am using
very simple heuristics where you just
say okay here the object and you say
well I can't grab it now this looks like
it's in the way so what you're doing
then you just drive it and get it all
the way and then you look again and you
say hmm okay there's another one in the
way right so kind of simply your six
where you just say take them away
kind of one after the other might get us
actually pretty far already and of
course then the idea would be that these
heuristics you can train in very large
simulation so that the deep networks for
example can decode these heuristics well
so I'm I'm not sure we need really very
complicated all the rearrangement
planning for that we can do it often
yeah so beyond so you're using it on the
robot and also are there other sensors
they can intercept in the you
ideally want to have that maybe today I
think you could also mention a
combination but clearly for example for
the home setting where you don't want to
put death cameras everywhere or if for
example if you want to get an object out
of a drawer then clearly it's good to
have a camera on the robot so that it
can actually look in through the drawer
we also carry our cameras with us it
turns out actually it's tricky where to
place them right if you have of course
on the grip is one but if you want to
have something closer to let's say a
human head position on a robot on a
mobile base there it's actually pretty
terrible because you have this fixed
viewpoint and sometimes you want to be
able to kind of to lean over and look
into something so it's very difficult
actually to where to best place these
cameras in industrial settings you can
imagine also putting more like cameras
outside because the industrial robots
they don't have any any perception right
now on them which touch I think is I
think the one I would love most having
much better like touch skin on this
robot it's not only on the fingers but
also on the arms and everywhere right
and people are looking at that but it's
still I don't think it's ready for prime
time yet there will be my dream sensor
[Applause]